In this video we will be reviewing how to create a scan in Burp Suite Enterprise Edition.
You can create one-off scans or schedule recurring scans. Please note that before you can create any
scans you need to create a site. Additionally your scanning machine must be able to access
the sites that you want to scan. For information on allowing access please see our documentation
configuring your environment network and firewall settings. To create a new scan we can navigate
to the scans tab and then select new scan in the top right corner. We can then select our site from
the site tree. By default the scan will start as soon as possible. Additionally we can select a
schedule to schedule the scan for a particular date and time. By default that scan will recur weekly.
We can amend this based on our desired scan schedule. We can then repeat the scan either
forever, a set number of times, or until a particular date. Additionally we can run the scan just the once.
If you'd like to enable additional logging we can also select enable verbose logging for this scan.
Please note this is only really advised when troubleshooting scan issues. Once we've entered
the required details we can click save. The scan will be distributed to an available scanning machine.
Notice that in this case the scan is queued. If we'd schedule the scan it will be identified as scheduled.
Thank you.